pour participer à la présidentielle il
faut être un bon chasseur de signature
[Musique]
et oui pour être candidat il faut
récolter au moins 500 parrainages d'élus
une vraie course de fond pendant
plusieurs mois avant le premier tour et
parfois cela se joue à la dernière
minute à quelques signatures près
c'était le cas de josé bové le candidat
des verts en 2007 jusqu'à ce soir on va
pas être capable de pouvoir être certain
de ce qui va se passer et même on aura
toujours une part d'incertitude dans la
mesure où des parrainages oda avait
directement conseil constitutionnel or
depuis mercredi soir n'y a plus de
chiffrage fait pas le conseil
constitutionnel donc on a pas de retour
sur ce qui aurait pu rentrer donc voilà
donc on est dans une incertitude et il
faudra attendre très certainement lundi
pour vérifier si oui ou non on a toutes
les signatures et au final josé bové a
bien eu ses 500 signatures mais sur le
fil le coeur du problème c'est que ces
parrainages sont rendus publics et oui
un maire doit être transparent sur le
candidat qu'il parraine mais s'il donne
sa signature à quelqu'un qui n'est pas
de sa famille politique il peut subir
des pressions d'où le refus de certains
maires de donner leur signature alors
faut-il rendre ces parrainages anonyme
c'est déjà ce que demande et marine le
pen en 2012 il est largement temps
de changer cette modalité qui consiste à
livrer en réalité la liste des noms des
mères à la vindicte de quelques milices
d'extrême gauche ou aux pressions de
quelques oligarques ump ou socialiste se
veut de marine le pen n'a pas été exaucé
aujourd'hui les parrainages des
candidats sont toujours public en fait
dans l'histoire du front national c'est
un peu une tradition de dénoncer ce
système de course aux signatures on se
la larme en disant qu'on aura passé 500
parrainages et on crie au scandale
démocratique pas vrai jean marie le pen
à deux mois du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle il ya quelques
jours de l'envoi des formulaires
officiels par le conseil constitutionnel
et ce malgré une série de démarches qui
dure depuis cinq mois je n'ai pas encore
réunies ni 500 promesses de signatures
tout le monde ou presque s'accorde à
dire qu'il serait scandaleux et d'hommes
et dommageable pour la démocratie et
pour la république que je ne puisse par
défaut de parrainage être candidat au
final jean marie le pen sera bien
candidat en 2007 sans problème pas de
quoi s'inquiéter en réalité dans une
campagne présidentielle
même dans la chasse aux signatures il
faut faire preuve d'un peu de stratégie
politique
[Musique]